affaire judiciaire entre rt france et
nicolas tenzer notre chaîne a porté
plainte contre ces propos qu'elle
jugeait diffamatoires mais avait posté
sur twitter fin 2018 la justice
française l'a finalement relaxé estimant
qu'ils exprimaient que des jugements de
valeur ou des opinions rt france
conteste cette décision et va faire
appel sachez par ailleurs que nicolas
tenzer a été débouté de ses demandes de
condamner arte france a payé elle 50000
euros de dommages intérêts pour
procédure abusive ainsi que 5000 euros
au titre de ses frais de procédures je
vous propose d'écouter la réaction de
jérémie assous l'avocat berthet france
c'est extrêmement décevant mais
malheureusement pas surprenant puisque
depuis carte existe elle subit un
traitement totalement différent voire
discriminatoire par rapport à tous les
autres médias
ont eu refuse l'accès à la salle de
presse de l'elysée dès qu'elle se
constitue partie civile dans à la suite
de propos qui sont gravement
diffamatoires le les juridictions et les
tribunaux pour l'instant pas encore la
cour d'appel mais que les tribunaux
relaxes systématiquement les personnes
poursuivies tu es vraiment deux poids
deux mesures vous avez la jurisprudence
et les règles de droit qui s'applique
pour tous les médias puis vous avez une
application qui est différente si vous
êtes certes et nous allons interjeter
appel
j'ai encore l'espoir que les magistrats
de la cour d'appel de paris
reprennent et applique les jurisprudence
habituelle en matière de diffamation et
ne
confère pas un statut différent et des
lois et des jeux expérience différente
suivant le média que vous représentez rt
respecte toutes les législations en
vigueur dans chacun des pays dans
lesquels elle émet notamment en france
il n'y a pas de raison qu'un bénéficient
pas la protection inhérentes à la
législation française